foreign
here we are oh my God you know I promise
everybody that my what camera am I
looking at here okay I I made a promise
to Isaiah but not just to promise a
something that I wanted to celebrate the
fact that you were you were the first
champion of the week I was the president
yes and also you're somebody thank you
thank you everyone yeah we tested on it
no we're clapping amazing live audience
here we are clapping uh for the fact
that Isaiah was the first in-person
guest but of course
having you on for five minutes doesn't
do you justice
um it doesn't because I was actually um
sorry to cut you off but I was a little
hurt that it's taking this long to get
my own well I know right well but you're
the first yeah you're the first I felt
used and I was like you're the first
in-person guest yeah you know and it
actually it it was almost Mike O'Hearn
and it was almost Noel daisell to for
the first because I like well I hit him
up the other day I was like oh I really
want to get Michael Hearn in the studio
and talk to him because we actually
we've been training as you know and and
we always just have interesting
conversations like I think he's a he's a
thoughtful and opinionated guy and not
every person in Fitness is like that
right you can take some people here like
cool he has a great physique but what
can he talk about he seems intelligent
he's very intelligent I used to watch it
as like tutorial videos but yeah yeah
but you've worked out them you said that
he actually knows correct I mean so not
only is a good coach and Mentor but then
like you can fire him up on anything but
give me your take on what's happening in
the world and I don't think he Styles
himself as like a geopolitical expert
but he has interesting insights into you
know the way that he thinks our country
or the world's headed so I feel like we
always there's always some launching off
point when we train for a deeper
conversation and I also feel like we
have good conversations too so
um I say all that to not say that you're
my third choice no that's actually
exactly what it sounds like in my head
I'm like okay where's he going with this
you're just right here exactly oh my man
I really you know I'm fortunate that at
least Isaiah could come
um but I'm joking by the way also I was
talking to you yesterday about how I
hope that your podcast uh starts up
again I know you're super busy but like
the episodes that I watched you on also
evolve as a podcast host and a podcaster
because I think you're compelling in a
long format and also the skill of
keeping a conversation going especially
like you have Kristen you have
potentially two guests in the room
somebody off to the side you playing
traffic cop out of the conversation yeah
I can I do love podcasting yeah look I
love talking I mean you could literally
talk all day yeah but just like you said
I'm just so busy because you know it is
I need the coordinator I was telling you
yesterday yes can I try to coordinate my
skin it's coordinate my YouTube videos
trying to get so many people say yeah I
need a planner to get me guests yeah you
know because I could do it but it's just
like great you know how it is it's this
additional element and I always tell you
like what are the big things holding me
back of doing more skits on my own is
like oh then I gotta call people and
coordinate that's the hardest part you
know and Casey and I talk about this
where it's like and you know Casey books
a lot of guests and does the
coordination of their travel and getting
the food trucks and it's like
it because it's not something that could
be done in a finite amount of time no
you can't just be like I'm gonna book
The the bot the food truck in the next
30 minutes also it's like baby maybe
they want to do it maybe this guy's
going to be more difficult than not or
maybe you know somebody wants you know
like we're dealing with somebody right
now who wants all these different things
from their accommodations and it's like
now it's a negotiation over the course
of multiple days wait Casey you're in
charge of that yeah for full time damn
damn bro
exactly it's probably a hard thing for
you to do too right AC
by just going back and forth non-stop
yeah
yeah Casey wears a lot of hats he's very
and he's also a very talented actor and
stunt man and uh you know edits he
produces all this stuff so yeah I think
it's good to be you know I'm gonna be
checking over here and periodically yeah
oh my goodness yeah um
yeah exactly so you know one of the
things that I'm always like
I will
sometimes in the moment you know and you
saw me I'm like texting work stuff back
and forth as I'm doing this and you have
various frustrations going on because
you're like it almost feels silly when
you're like I'm I'm in the middle of
shooting a skit right now how dare you
text me with the work applications
because this is something that's like
extra but I'm so very fortunate to just
be able to be around people like you
primarily you know and other people who
coordinate with us like nap and anybody
else has shot with us
um it's fortunate for me
to be part of that Machinery yeah and I
take it for what it is like look I'm not
the star I'm not the ultimate driving
force yourself
what I'm saying is you wonder it's okay
to be a part of something I consider
that a community that I'm grateful to be
a part of and we put the pre-solid team
like yeah I mean you first started
shooting sketches probably over a year
now but like we've come a long way yeah
the production everything's gotten
better we have a little solid you know
team of recurring guests correct people
really [ __ ] like it yeah and and it
does help I think with everything and
you see that on bigger Hollywood
Productions is that these units move
together these production units of like
you know the Pirates of the Caribbean
it's not like they're hiring different
people every time they shoot a different
movie like they use the same people
ideally because you end up working
together but sometimes I forget how
short it's been since you've come to LA
because we met in what was it March I
think it was something like that it was
around one two twenty one this November
will be two full years here oh wow okay
yeah so I did I didn't know you when you
first came but then when I started going
to zoo
um you know shortly there after we shot
our first sketch in that so I don't know
what your following was like since then
but like maybe you could just kind of
briefly talk about
coming to LA and like what your mindset
has been because the from an outside
perspective your ability to keep up a
constant rate of work in content
production and and and be the driving
force in that because not me like you
say oh you're you know like I know you
appreciate me but like I'm not the
person coordinating and coming up with
the stuff and blah blah like I can add
my part to it but like there always has
to be somebody driving it so tell us
about your intention and how you feel
like that's
matching up or not to you well first of
all when I first came out here my
content everything was so different but
I came out here I told you I canceled my
flight to end up staying that was when I
was strictly Just Fitness based I had no
idea what I was doing though I was just
Instagram was really my biggest thing I
was posting YouTube here and there but
knew nothing about it yeah
um and then the more I got into fitness
I was you know social media following is
probably around like 150 no like 200k
around there then the whole you know 21
test thing came out that's actually how
I first found out about you yeah I
realized it was you
um like meeting I was like oh wait that
was the guy that everyone like but but
yeah oh wait that's the little girl that
everyone thought right it was funny like
what a huge deal obviously everybody
made about this but yes I saw it and I
put it away mentally and then I met you
and then later I was like oh that was
the guy that I saw before and then I
kind of just honestly I think if that
didn't happen I probably honestly
wouldn't have started shooting like
sketches and stuff I mean like I acted
and stuff in high school in college and
I said oh really so you wouldn't have
started doing sketches I guess it kind
of led me into town I don't know because
before you answer that
oh oh yeah
he's getting fired up
oh yeah that was good
um I'd be meaning to do this at the
beginning this was me taking off my yeah
wife beater so that I can put on an oak
and stone shirt because you can't do
that with oakenstone I heard dude you're
right it's like this material like you
could you know that was pretty easy and
effortless like I gave it a little bit
of a you know oh no this is so tough for
a second there just to show you that
like but you can't with that at all just
to make it dramatic really yeah it would
be literally impossible for me so that
was a very smooth transition into me
having my shirt upside down yeah
when you can get it on
visibility which is funny because
earlier I was like you're so flexible
exactly lower body not upper body
um oh and it does hurt it does like
affect my shoulders don't completely
[ __ ] up okay we're almost there oh my
God we got it here we go edit that out
um
here's Duncan Stone shirt uh promo code
hella 10 off at checkout so use it tell
me how I'm actually fascinated because I
haven't heard this before how you
decided to start doing sketches because
of the 21 times well I'm gonna say
that's like the reason I started doing
but it was definitely a different route
because yeah up to that point I guess I
was strictly kind of just doing Fitness
content and then when the whole thing
came out last lot of followers getting a
lot of [ __ ] hate really you lost
followers completely I was like I was
kind of like handled them like
blacklisted for a while like anything on
post Fitness yeah I don't want to listen
to this guy No One's Gonna say shut the
[ __ ] up you don't know ow I didn't
realize it was that bad so yeah I mean
it was something that you know me I
don't really care about comments it
doesn't the stuff like that doesn't
really affect me you're very resilient
which is why I think thank you which is
why I think people I started gaining you
know a loyal following and gaining
people back so yo I because even the
people that used to hate me like you you
know what I really respect you because
the whole thing came out you didn't stop
doing anything right I noticed that
posted I didn't care yeah and let me
just differentiate that too because
this is something that I like you know
you've told me like uh Noel was like oh
he looks like he's mad at responding to
haters you know that like I'm not saying
it it's like to say it has zero percent
of effect on me well it obviously does
because I'm responding to like I'm aware
of it but what you're saying is like it
doesn't
go to this point of affecting my
behavior or like when I tell you I'm
like like if you could put your finger
on my on my heart rate and measure this
it would be like the stress I feel
playing a video game or something it's
like sure like I'm not you know it's not
at 40 bpms like I just woke up and I'm
in a brain fog yeah but like it's
certainly far below this level of like
anger or altering my mind
correct and that's the big
differentiator I was going to say is
that like it's altering my behavior like
I'm fitting any [ __ ] talking I'm doing
into like you know like you know and not
not being obsessed with it or or letting
it like you know somebody's like
nobody's ever said something mean to me
online enough yeah it makes you spent
the day right and I'm not saying that
was always the case I'm just saying I've
built up and maybe you're you know more
psychologically resilient at an earlier
age but the the important thing is
you've developed a sense of self that is
resilient to those kinds of criticisms
uh as far as an observer could tell yeah
right which is almost the most important
I mean I've always had a kind of I guess
thick skin but it's like my biggest
thing is like I'm you know me I'm so
[ __ ] driven and I know exactly what I
want I want to let these random people
that don't know me make me stop like
yeah I mean that's just what doesn't get
was there ever like is there any voice
in your head that like lets that in and
then there's just a stronger voice that
yeah I mean I'm not to say that nothing
affects me no okay obviously there'll be
like one or two out of a hundred that
I'm like oh yeah that one kind of hurt
like you might like you're talking about
like my acne yeah
because I used to have really bad acne
when I was younger yeah I won an
Accutane I think I told you for a little
bit Yeah but a quick sign of the
funniest the worst I think comment or
anything that I got before because you
know little kids are really yeah um
honest right yeah I was younger I was in
high school acne was crazy my little
brother's friend came up to me looked at
me in the face the straightest face I
was like have you heard SpongeBob
so he looks at me he's like
why do you have Barnacles all over your
face
and I literally was like I didn't know
how you don't know how to respond you're
just like I was like could we get a
picture of that little kid yeah yeah
and the sunglasses I literally was like
I like them like I didn't know how to
respond you know what I mean but those
are like no very rarely do I get a
comment where I'm like that's another
interesting one where I go there's
things that
people don't know
wouldn't hurt you like they think it's
gonna hurt you but then stuff like I
remember having acne growing up and that
did really hurt because it was something
you can't change and like you're not
accepting of it you know like if
somebody tells me I have a big nose
today or something I'm like I'm okay
with my nose I'm okay with my lips I'm
okay with like anything that you've
critiqued about my body like I either
have accepted it or I'm working on
changing it you know what I mean if
somebody tells like oh your arms are
small it's like yeah I'm working on them
or whatever you know but the active
thing was like I don't accept it I want
it to change I hope that nobody sees it
but then you're seeing it and pointing
it out in the most vicious but like
innocent way possible as a kid you can't
even be like well he's just a hater
he's asking about bother girls the kid
wants a biology lesson but um but the
thing about acne is that what people
don't understand that don't have acne is
like they think that just because you
have it because you don't take care of
yourself you don't clean your skin but
no we probably take care of our skin is
the most out of anyone take dollar
protocols yeah you know and football I
used to have uh one of the assistants
literally carry around like pads and
stuff I used to have pads in wrestling
and they're probably [ __ ] your skin up
more because you don't like I have no
idea but anybody's saying like it's a
matter of dirty skin it's like no no my
skin is like peeling off my face yeah
but but anyway by circling back it's
like
um yeah I don't like I don't let any of
that stuff stop me like the comments and
everything you know yeah maybe it's just
the acne and where did that where did
that have you always had that because
we've actually talked about some of this
stuff like I used to cheat in high
school not to say you out here but I
would do the same thing now I'd get like
an A in the honors physics class totally
on my own in the structured class where
I knew I couldn't cheat but it was like
I think you and I are like this [ __ ]
class like let me just you know so my
ambition was not to be a perfect student
but my ambition was to do well and like
by any means necessary but I like the
challenge of actually a well-structured
Fair class yeah but like it's almost
like the easiest classes I would cheat
more in yeah because I'm like this is
the whole class is [ __ ] I'm not
gonna do anything yeah but some of the
stuff you told me you come up with them
like this dude's a hustler I used to
have a [ __ ] Bluetooth microphone case
I'm not joking I said Bluetooth earpiece
I used to wear put a beanie over it I'll
be on the phone with one of my friends
that's in a different school and what
we're hearing you know which is probably
a lot of people related to this it's
more effort to put the system in place
to cheat than it would have been to
study for an hour
I like it it's fun for me right because
it's invigorating because you would
literally be like talking to me like I
was sending pictures of it and he'll be
talking like right X plus b equals blah
blah and when I when I cough that means
repeat it you know like when I click my
panic I swear to God I'm not joking I
swear to God and I Pat and I passed I
literally got that was in um
pre-calculus
yeah that's impressive that's impressive
because again it's like which is why I
use that same effort and put into my
skits today but the thing is like stuff
like that you just learn you get [ __ ]
done you might be the right way but you
get [ __ ] done you know and that's kind
of how I always like
um look at life where it's like people
are very scared of consequences it's
like if I'm not going to jail like
what's the school's gonna catch me like
you know cheating on a test and okay
okay then I'll study for it and take it
speaking of school like I know you
finished but it's one of those things
that like you don't need like oh it
conditions you whatever that is school
conditions you unless you're a doctor a
lawyer or something like that you
conditioned you to work a nine to five
job it's finding out what you're good at
yeah let's put this robot in the world
now and just do this yeah and for guys
like you and I like this is when I was
in education I subbed for many years I
actually taught you know an English
class I was a after school tutor for
like SATs and math prep like any test
prep in the you know they have the isces
and middle school test um so I'm
familiar with working with kids and
anytime I'd meet a guy like you or a
young man or I'm like you're you got a
quality yeah either you're funny or
you're ambitious or you're just like
this isn't stimulating you
and every teacher in this environment is
going to tell you that you're bad in
some way or you're wrong or you need to
change but I'm I want to be the guy
whispering and I'm like hey you need to
survive this but
to a degree yeah because then you have
to be a teacher yeah but like I went
through
you know like I went through school it
was just like had I known more about
whatever like you know I got all A's in
my acting classes I was like oh I should
have been doing this the whole time you
know what I mean instead of being like
and I majored in political science it
just wasn't like that interesting I
liked it but it's like yeah
there's a lot of kids out there who can
out essay write me at you know one of
the best colleges in the country
um so I'm not that guy but nobody's
gonna like tell you your strengths
necessarily yeah especially in high
school whatever they're focused on being
like no you're making money and it's
survival for the teacher because you're
like hey you're making my life difficult
yeah shut the f up and behave they have
a job too but yes I could be as a
teacher I could try to be like and plant
a little seed of like oh hey if you
could look up this online course or do
this or you know don't let somebody tell
you that this is a valuable skill yeah
and that I think does carry forward so
that was my mindset like in high school
like I knew I was in school person I
knew that for a fact and you I knew
College was wasn't for me but I went
just because you know I had no Lily no
idea what I was doing and I'm kind of
just like pleased my parents yeah I'm in
college you know but then I you know I
dropped out a lot to them oh right yeah
the life that you were like I was lying
because it was on it was on it was
online yeah so I'm like yeah I'm
downstairs I have computer work to go do
oh my God right
I was doing school full-time working two
jobs full time right
no that's inside one of those things
like a 19 year old having a full-time
job I'd be like I don't want to like I
don't care about anything else from that
kid he's working and doing social trying
to do the social media yeah but covet
kind of picked it up then came back here
but you knew like did you see a future
for yourself I had no idea I just knew
that I was going to be something big in
this world yeah I was always my God I
want to leave my Mark I want to have an
impact I want to do I know I'm going to
be so you were born a narcissist
that's okay because I like that you're
confident in saying that because you've
expressed things to me before like I
want my ambition is to be the biggest
Entertainer and I look at you and I go
there's nothing stopping you from doing
that except other people in your way
yeah so you just have to figure out how
to crush those people underneath your
boot in order to get what you want
that's not my intention but it has to
happen no right but I'll just use that
thought by saying you have the skills
and the drive and it's just like as I
said other people's decisions or
gatekeeping yeah is really you know how
you navigate something well you know but
you know I'm very big on and I always
say there's so much success out here for
everyone yeah I want everyone to [ __ ]
win right you know I mean because I
think anyone can do anything you want
right I'm very big on speaking things
into existence and yeah station yeah if
you want something just [ __ ] go work
your ass off yeah I've because I've
almost never heard you and that's a good
point but I'll reflect on it because
sometimes you get around really
successful people sometimes they're like
yeah like oh this person sucks or that
person sucks and it's like you don't
need to do that in order for you to see
you know and but you don't do that some
people do need it though yeah I really
if you know what you're talking about I
really don't um like think of you as
somebody who's ever like sometimes you
will measure yourself against somebody
like you were like for example you're
like well Adam W puts out a skit every
day and I have to remind you I'm like he
has a bigger team than you he like he's
yeah
because it was a real conversation I'm
like if you're measuring yourself
against the standard and like driving
yourself nuts to just put out a sketch
every day because this other guy on the
internet who has been doing it for way
longer and has more people in his
service to make the whole process of
that content creation smoother for him
yeah and you're taking on you're
producing essentially and doing more of
these tasks wearing more of the hats
like it's okay move yourself permission
to not drive yourself nuts and when you
told me that I was like I remember I was
like oh my thank you because it
sometimes I'll put a sketch just to put
it out the day and it wasn't even a good
one you know what I mean so I'm very big
on now and what you see the qualities
going up yeah but uh yeah but a lot of
rain scenes you know what I'm saying
bangers but um yeah quality over
quantity which is why I'm mostly that's
my focus now yeah um I still try to do
like one a day but if I don't post one
in a day I'll be okay with it which is
bringing me back to yes I want Adam Adam
W's first was very good friend yeah um
someone I do look up to a lot which is
awesome because he's like one of the
goats of the internet sketch game yeah
it's like he's like you're looking up to
him for a reason but don't think you
have to be him every day yeah but the
goal is to catch him and be right you
know what I mean yeah I want all success
for him too but I want to be you know I
want to be best right is that a bad
thing to say no I don't think so at all
no
um but then and then escalating from
that from the skits do you know how I'm
trying to get into acting now you know
yes so I have I've been auditioning as
you know he's you found me a couple of
self tapes I have a manager for that so
trying to the ones I helped you with I
feel like the the self tapes ended up
being way better than no they actually
were like these were the worst ones yeah
um
they were great and um I think every
single self tape I do gets better and
better and you know when he had I mean
you've done Bunch so you know me doing
you like yo I [ __ ] nailed that you
know what I mean and then you don't get
called back it's like but then you have
to remind yourself there's a million
other people doing it do you know what I
mean yeah so it's like for sure that's
another thing that comes with the
repetition that I've even like when I
first started acting I tell my mom I had
an audition and then send her like you
make this big production out of like
sending in an audition and then your mom
said what happened oh like yeah you know
how many times my family's like oh how's
acting how's acting going how's
auditioning yeah it's like hard to
condition them to a one-word response
almost because you don't ever want to be
like oh it's going really good and then
like suddenly you're not getting
auditions so you have to like explain
that when it's out of your control yes
so you can answer in terms of like the
things that I control are going well
yeah I'm getting better at auditioning
which I have been like my my managers um
they were like they'll tell me that oh
you're doing a lot better you're doing
much better yeah
um they're like yeah we saw an audition
from this guy named Helen Mark Harley
was trashed
um but yeah so as long as I'm getting
better
no do they no okay but they do see
because we wouldn't even be yeah like we
wouldn't even be Audrey no we need to
start our own yeah like you know he even
heard of key and peel they heard yeah
have you heard of the uh The Young and
the Restless this would be the The Young
and the old guy yeah but it would go
it'll go crazy though maybe the real
hellmark Harley Puerto Rican Twice The
Young and the rest up bro you look tired
The Young and the excessive rest period
but um but yeah so that's that's the
goal that's to get into acting being my
you know movies TV shows um I mean I
wouldn't just do everything I say all
the time yes which is why I can get on
my own head sometimes you know right
because you go you go what is it not
happening fast enough it's just I always
I'm out at a million Tick Tock followers
almost we're 35k away that's today's two
bangers I know no yeah 35kway which I
said we're celebrating yes we have a
little party because I honestly you know
I joke around a lot but I wouldn't be at
where I'm at now if it wasn't for you
and obviously thank you you know Lexi
Noelle nap Chris you know I have a good
team around me yeah no when you when you
actually said that you were gonna
celebrate hitting a million I'm like
that's a good idea that's a part of the
that I can get behind because sometimes
I mean you're probably the same way like
I don't know how big of a deal you make
birthdays I'm not big on my birthday
right I have a self-consciousness as
many men do of going like celebrate me
just because I was born you want to be
like no I want to have done something
yeah then we can celebrate you know
that's why I'm not big on my birthday
which you know like my family like
normal things I'm kind of crazy for it's
like I'm not beginning because I to me I
haven't done anything yet yeah you know
what I mean yeah obviously I'm grateful
I'm alive I'm not saying that I have
hello family friends you know yeah it
feels a little weird to be like yeah
like we're having a party yeah like what
happened yeah and you could tell me
happy birthday like I get it you know
what I mean like I get it yeah yeah but
we're celebrating this but you know the
people there's two types of people
people that don't care about the
birthday and people that set a reminder
30 days ahead you that remind you guys
the glow day in 30 days that's Chris by
the way
but uh but yeah the million party will
happen twice in this week you throw them
under the bus you made him the fat guy
in the mirror in your schedule you know
when people were like yo oh damn you did
Chris so crazy no that made me LOL yeah
but uh Chris is Chris is the
representation of you having buy the
dysmorphia yes and gave me like 50
pounds in the sketch oh Chris looks
great
exactly he's bulking he's bulky guys he
does know he looks leaner than he did
last year oh way better yeah way better
um but yeah that's that's the goal
um you know Entertainer overall now is
being swole how does like swole as the
goal play into this because you've
noticed under the sweater I'm getting
much bigger yeah I didn't know if you
wanted me to take it I actually have
yeah
um no but it's honestly one of those
things too that like I feel I told you
yesterday I think I told you yesterday
two days ago like this is the best I
felt yeah like physically you know body
wise which also translates it translates
to work you know I mean you're confident
right and so when when you're you know
first starting Instagram
you had told me that you were like
working out twice a day and kind of
doing crazy stuff in order to get I mean
you were very shredded yeah and I think
that's what people don't realize is like
but it's not sustainable right in order
to look like that he looked amazing but
it's like that is not fun it's not and
also you're probably doing an
inefficient Way by doing more work
versus like oh if I just monitor my diet
really carefully I've learned since I've
done a show in the couple months you
have learned so much like before when I
first saw I was shredded probably for
like months and months and months I
almost stage shredded for months and
months yeah felt like [ __ ] when I look
back at pictures I look sick like in the
face no literally I'm like yeah I can't
believe I look like no because I
remember seeing a picture of you or like
the first video
like talking about to you know the
response to uh the 21 nanograms thing
and you look your face look different oh
my God yeah and I look I look sick I
look like a little boy I look like I was
17 like 16. haven't hit puberty you look
bombed out and depleted yeah yeah no I
did
um but yeah so but thing is when you
start social media and you start getting
the likes at that time my engagement was
ridiculous I was hitting the explore
page like a million times before yeah
like my engagement my Impressions I was
hitting a million two million like every
other picture yeah so like you see that
and you're like oh [ __ ] this is working
let me get leaner let me correct that's
yeah
it's not just like you know when I'm
growing up and uh you know Polaroid
cameras are all the rage that was always
that was our social media but then and
then you give that to a carrier pigeon
and the girl that was cute yeah and then
I moved out to LA obviously and that's
you know stuff I'm starting to get known
more so it's like right it's addicting
it's a Nifty feeling correct because I'm
going like like I had the opposite
growing up or I'm like oh gaining weight
like for football was the thing that I
became obsessed with so like I never had
this I've been lean before but like
building an identity around like I'm the
lean guy yeah that's that was my
experience I was just shredded yeah I
was literally known to be lean in the
cardio king of people because I used to
do circuits and all that yeah for cardio
yeah running miles and miles and miles
yeah um I still pretty much just did
everything and was there a point
was there a point when you were like
I don't want to do this anymore but I
have to keep it up that's when when I
saw my test was that low that's not like
this is bad yeah I can't do anything but
that was like a wake-up call honestly
yeah
um and that was kind of like what got me
into honestly changing my content
because oh at that time too before that
all happened when we first moved to LA
all my content was like swipe workouts
so it was like yeah I would work out
then I'll do a workout video for
Instagram so people could you know swipe
and save them and blah blah yeah I
wouldn't just never do sketches maybe
like a workout then a picture workout
then a picture knowing you know like
completely transitioned from it my my
assumption about that would be like
that's boring as [ __ ] right but because
I look at that uh like I have some stuff
to offer like as far as workout tips or
whatever but like my brain immediately
goes like but that's boring and so many
other people are doing some people love
it because it's like okay oh let me do
this workout you know they look at your
physique if I do this workout it's gonna
yeah which I mean it's not usually that
can happen yeah but um but you were
doing it because like you rip people
paying attention I can do these workouts
here you have personalities are you
going to tell someone correct bench
press four times four sets of ten right
I'm so bored how long did that last like
you might have been excited at first
okay but like how long were you excited
about it then when you're like this is
starting to get repetitive the number
when I mean the numbers are going up I
loved it yeah because the numbers are
going up yeah this is working I'm gonna
keep doing it if it's not broke don't
fix it yeah except somebody with an
obligation of the feedback was like
feeling like all right well this is I
don't even give a [ __ ] I would literally
be I remember being injury specifically
I didn't post you know I'm trying to
post every day yeah didn't post a
workout
um because I didn't work out the dancing
rest day whatever I remember being at
Panera and I'm like [ __ ] I got to push
the workout get my friend a thing went
inside run in front of Panera at the
Benjamin did like a cardio bench workout
just to just a post right yeah you know
I mean it's just like it was so like I
have to use I have to yeah which is not
a terrible mentality to have because
almost like in any profession the answer
could be like if you were at a page a
day you'd have
um four scripts a year or whatever that
works out you know like you'd write 120
Pages at 120 days and that works out to
four months you'd have three scripts you
know
um if you can get yourself to do a unit
of thing every day the heart like I
guess
for somebody like you is more
extroverted getting the feedback of
posting a video helps yeah right but
like it's a path to success just because
you get in this habit and it might seem
a little bit crazy to other people but
you're like no no this is the repetition
and the absolute commitment to doing the
unit of thing every day I posted every
single day did not miss a day for like a
year and a half almost two years yeah
Instagram that's pretty crazy because
now I think about posting Instagram like
oh yeah especially because when
engagement goes you know how engagement
is you've got a couple of different
social media platforms yeah and my
engagement was really really high and
then it stalled out and like now it's
down but then it's always waves gonna go
up and down yeah but I mean I've lost I
was at 315 was my highest I'm at 305
which I've learned to condition myself
so that I have ten thousand haters right
but I've learned to condition myself to
not get obsessed with numbers because
yeah Instagram engagement might be down
but I'm about to hit a million on Tick
Tock you know yeah YouTube shorts I'm
really pushing shorts if you didn't hear
shorts they're gonna start monetizing in
January no that's good to know I'm gonna
start uploading all the all my stuff to
uh YouTube but yeah you're because I
also see like it's kind of funny because
Instagram used to kind of be your bread
and butter for like but I do think it
leans towards like hot girls and like
really shredded guys like the physique
the image still is King even though
they're trying to make it about reels
like that like people go to tick tock
for that you're crushing them and and
the YouTube shorts thing I was gonna say
like I get recognized probably the most
thing that I get recognized from is your
tick tocks and Instagram shorts yeah no
you know and people don't know by name
they're just like they go are you on
Tick Tock oh yeah I get that even though
yes I am on Tick Tock yeah yeah you know
anybody with a profile is on Tick Tock
but I actually even get recognized
mostly now used to be Instagram yo your
body looks crazy I won't look like you
you know yeah you know it's great
they're sitting there eating McDonald's
with me yeah yeah they have five Big
Macs like he does
um but then then it transitioned to yo I
love your tick tocks are hilarious you
know yeah now it's actually yo I love
your shorts I see you all the time on
YouTube without Secrets right some of
these will hit like a few million or
would you say your biggest my biggest
one is like 42 mil right 42 million then
have a couple 30 Millions then yeah
yeah no it's cool because I said like Oh
They'll pop up at my feet I'm like oh
[ __ ] I got like 10 million you know 5
million so it's all about just being
consistent with it because once you get
that wave because I was watching Mr
Beast listen um listening to Mr Beast on
a podcast and he was talking about how
short it's gonna be the next big thing
because yeah they're gonna start dude
they're gonna make that change first of
all they're gonna split two tabs now so
for one for long form videos and one for
shorts because now it's together so it
looks cluttered on your feet it looks
great it looks kind of gross which is
why a lot of people don't post it oh get
out of my no yeah bro but once people
once they make that transition there's
apparently what he was saying there's
going to be a push of how Tick Tock had
its first initial wave of big creators
like the Addison rage the the Bryce
Halls the Charlie demilius the shorts is
going to have its own wave of
influencers which I already think I'm at
the top of the game for shorts you know
right yeah you position yourself not
from akaki you it's a professional
perspective but I think my quality is
very good and I think it's a perfect
short so when they modernize I'm gonna
want to get my beak wet so oh you can
always get your feet no no but um but
yeah and they're going to start doing
that he's a toucan yeah but Tick Tock
doesn't
um they're at their um what's the word
I'm looking for
they're they're monitoring okay yeah I
don't do tick tocks to make money on
Tick Tock does anybody I mean like
because you're crushing they have almost
a million followers and like not all of
your videos hit crazy viral but like you
have a lot that are millions and
millions yeah that doesn't get you any
money no I think the last time I checked
my Creator fund was probably a couple
months ago and for the two years I was
doing it four pennies one and a half
years ago it was like there was like six
thousand dollars in it oh wait okay
that's not that bad but that's two years
though correct and you're like I can get
a brand deal for you know right you have
a million for almost a million followers
and no but I've gotten Millions two
years I mean yeah what's the total like
what's the view count that led to six
thousand oh I don't know so I oh just
whatever the total views a billy yeah
yeah well likes I want to say my likes
on my Tic Tacs probably around like 40
million likes yeah because I've seen
that before like when I see your bit I'm
like oh damn that's a lot of likes I can
check right now actually
um but yeah you don't do tic tacos B
lichen I do tickets I can't even get
into my own Tick Tock account oh yeah
you can yeah yeah but um connected to an
old number so like actually I can lap I
can log into a laptop and that's
probably good because do I need another
addictive social media app on my phone
that I'm swiping yeah
right exactly
okay but like what's funny is because
I've been positioned by you like people
will still hate on you or whatever
through that dumb [ __ ] 21 nanograms
but because I'm more neutral to your
audience they don't hit on me yeah but
because like I got a big or a bigger
following because of Brendan it's like
you inherit those haters because of bro
you know what I mean it's like this it's
like you don't even know why you hate me
I just appeared and you're like [ __ ]
this guy well actually don't like I mean
thankfully enough I don't get that much
hate anymore yeah um and people
genuinely actually love us together they
love our skits and like me you Noah Lexi
all this but like people like you know
you guys need your show you need to stay
calm which we do yeah this is
whoever wants to pick us up who wants to
pick us up who wants to have a whole
show about shitty gym skates yeah
that's why I do a lot of I do a lot of
outside gym ones too yeah but I think I
actually will say this that
um
you know
haters will say that we're not the best
gym comedy oh on planet okay 100 episode
title there we go yeah no 100
um and I think because now the bar is
low I'll say that like it's not like
people are revolutionizing it but you
like
that's a compliment about you as an
entrepreneur is you kind of like I don't
know anybody else who is really doing
like written out gym skits and kind of
exploring those things that it's so ripe
to explore in just the world of being at
the gym and the things that can happen
and like the one that you said was super
viral for you the 40 million with Noel
is like hitting when a girl thinks
you're hitting on her at the gym it's
very relatable so there's all these
relatable scenarios and that was right
for somebody to come in and mine it what
you see a lot of now is like one person
will hit something funny like oh I
slipped like on a banana peel and now
I'm doing chest on leg day it's like how
many times did you see that exact same
thing like frame by frame and it's like
that's not funny to just take somebody's
exact now be inspired by it do your own
thing but like for some reason we're
still in that phase of Jim comedy where
people are like oh I can put the rowing
handle between the person's butt cheeks
and like lift them up I'm like I bet you
know send it to me I'm like not only
have I seen that one before I've seen 10
other versions of that where it's not
inspired by it it's the exact same joke
the difference between being inspired
which I do get a lot of inspiration from
a lot of people when I'm on social media
actually I'm not doing it to be
entertained I'm doing it to be like okay
yeah what inspires me what's going to
spark something like okay I could do
this yeah you know what I mean um but
I've had people literally copy the exact
same video of me like the same oh
there's so much
it was just funny because people tag me
in it and then um the guy the person
just deletes them deletes the tags oh
really
I don't know so he's copying you and
then he's trying to cover up the fact
that he stole it this is like a word um
it was the one where Chris is like oh
you look great can we work out like yeah
we work out and I go to my phone to take
it on the needle comes out and I step oh
right because that was easy to that was
such a good idea the exact same video
exact same words in the exact same
outfit what black wife beater black
shorts it was like I thought it was like
I don't care you know there's this quote
from this Andrew Dominic movie uh the
assassination of Jesse James or the
coward Robert Ford go see it if you
haven't
um it was robbed of an Academy Award
2007 oh it's the best movie I've ever
seen what's the movie called it's called
the assassination of Jesse James by the
coward Robert Ford and it stars Brad
Pitt and uh Casey Affleck as Robert Ford
and uh Brad Pitt is Jesse James
in it he goes he turns to Casey Affleck
you know who's playing this guy who's
like obsessed with Jesse James and he
goes
you want to be like me or you want to be
me oh I haven't heard that man is that a
famous line from the quote probably yeah
I mean like Etc but anyway that reminded
me of that where it's like okay take my
idea but like you're dressing you know
you're doing it was hilarious influence
your haircut did he have the influencer
America no what do you call this with
this right here yeah I call it it was
falling out a couple days
[Laughter]
um no your hair looks great I'm saying
you know what I'm talking about though
there's actually a meme of Riley Reid
that I hope we can superimpose over this
where she's she has that haircut with
like the lightning bolts like in the
side or whatever and she goes you're
about to make me bust for real for real
No Cap oh god
um I don't know what I call this but uh
but yeah like I said I didn't care
um but overall goal yeah did Riley
readme it's gonna be kind of hard to
find I think I've looked for it before
like to see back to me has to be Riley
Reid for real No Cap uh that's gonna be
the one where this is the hill we're
gonna die in today but no you can go
keep talking no there we go
oh God you about to make me bust see
that looks like every tick tocker right
a little bit the meme is Riley Reid
going you're about to make me come yeah
but like it'll be like you know Joel
Romero is fighting on Bellator and it's
her face going like you're about to
watch Bellator you know oh I need to
change the ending of it yeah okay that's
funny um amazing meme right also real
quick
oh wow oh that's crazy I guess we gotta
no just because I know you have a fight
here guys Mark is the most hardest
[ __ ] worker I one of them I swear I
gotta know yeah
Casey I'm saying right now marked is the
most so he talks [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ]
me up okay I just don't consider myself
the hardest worker no I think I think
you're very hard worker I uh I try to do
a lot of things I'm just not great at
time management yeah you do do a lot and
I mean time management I think you're
good with
I mean I'd give myself a c minus yeah
sometimes you show that to my sketch
like an hour late no literally we'll be
like coming up for today but
um I'll be like yo eight o'clock Meetup
time it takes him at eight and then I'm
like yo where you at he's like you
actually thought I left my house right
now
oh no so we will probably have to wrap
it up here no I think we could yeah I do
have a flight to catch have you ever
tried creating before so this is happy
hippo herbals um which you can get at
happyhippo herbals.com use promo codes
thick boy for 20 off for the life okay
it's not just like a one-time promo code
what you do is you twist this thing and
then you just go
oh you hear that too
tastes good
hello Isaiah I developed a British
accent the last 20 seconds it's actually
good it is yeah
I like it this is grape delicious I'm
gonna have to try next time yo this is
good no cap for real for real okay
so I think we're gonna end it there
you're gonna be back I hope as a
recurring guest this only covers you
know the the tip of the iceberg this is
the iceberg it's not even we're not even
at the [ __ ] tip of where we're gonna
go yes this is just the tip this is not
just the tip it's a second episode title
so it can be like you know this episode
whatever I said before and then aka hey
just the tip yeah
include you know IMDb let's get it up
there all right good [ __ ] yeah good uh
thank you have a safe flight today yeah
I'll see you soon thank you
laughs